welcome to this video playing alma gr
from the US yeah lost a couple of points
from the last game i uploaded simply
because i played the get Jeter I played
this game like two weeks ago I ran
powers and he got bent but that I played
a guy with almost the same name Iran
powers 23 and I lost with some tactics
chat I reported him and he will be bent
but I lost like 20 rating points because
of that I don't understand what what
people get out of this alright so what
we get here or got here is some um
yanush gambit Freeman gambit out of the
room interesting line white didn't take
on c6 which allows this 95 mm of course
black has some structural issues here
but I have a very good night only five i
also have a good development let's let's
see if i take on e6 now yeah well maybe
you can play a night I have you for no I
can just do that threatening Bishop to
g4 yeah which he prevented what should I
do now I mean I can take but this one
does the bishop was check so I'm not a
good idea
not sure 26 rookie eight maybe need to
connect rooks how to do that how to play
without that came and then ruined baby
bishop just bag yeah poor Queen B phone
is one idea getting rid of the pin yeah
maybe I should go into D 72 bit bit more
interesting yeah okay not the end of the
world anyway queen bee phone or I can't
answer with c3 yeah but I need to I need
to get rid of the dependent that's let's
clear so let's let's go here attacking
the night and intending to take on d3 so
that i get the bishop pan
yeah probably just see three don't
really see them any great move for him
yeah so should I really take or is there
a shop c 8 was stupid why not to d7 and
then i would have had the opportunity to
play 96 at least this would have been an
idea not sure if it is great but if you
are able to play in a way that gives you
some additional ideas you should do that
okay how to play here yeah maybe go for
c5 yeah this I think is pretty good for
me unless there's some some direct way
to refuel it check simply because my
light squared Bishop will become very
strong should see five maybe Bishop c5
vb6 night takes c6 this could be a
problem if he retreats um yeah yeah I am
this is this concrete moves is the issue
well nothing nothing dramatic but at
least this means i'm not playing for an
EDM job that's unfortunate yeah i need
to do that long be 696 he can take on a
seven but this is rather risky I
wouldn't yeah well this I don't know
this I wouldn't have played that but
maybe I'm misjudging this this whole
situation
maybe now this this is an offside piece
and I can activate with Bishop f5 and so
on yeah I know I'm a pawn down but then
I don't think it matters so much
okay a drew can chew
look a six if I go here if I go rook a
six and cannot cannot trap it but I can
i man I can just play that one look back
and I take on a tomb or not the caption
a sin really was risky maybe maybe if he
plays something else something more
personas it's okay but the way it was
you're happy what's happened in the game
it was very risky okay yeah I can take I
can just take here why not actually it's
a temple and now just just be five orbit
read first yeah I can't retreat hers
before I thought f5 yeah well at least
for the moment I'm covering things and
93 he could have played Knight f3 this
would happen would have been very
annoying
because rookie oh no this this is a
chance I must take get rid of the night
before it comes to e5 now that's it just
push the stuff use the pawns org be
three
Bishop g7 us also not bad yeah this is
this is in fact quite quite okay it can
never really take it gives me protected
gives me a connected pawns yeah but I'm
promoting right I'm just promoting them
check
check I really managed in 20 seconds
time warning check check check Nate yeah
it wasn't as a difficult and game I
think he was too too optimistic here
here why does certainly okay yeah but
i'm not sure that taking is such a great
idea maybe maybe if he plays he plays
differently afterwards but it really
quickly become become became tricky and
now maybe somewhere here yeah this is
the problem this is the problem he needs
to play a three bishop b6 and then he
still has this pawn i mean i have some
compensation not sure if it is enough
probably probably not completely enough
but yeah this just lends them into into
big trouble and I thought it was much
easier to just to just take here but
probably I probably should take but play
more precisely afterwards now something
maybe something like this to try to try
to get this bag the bishop is is some
compensation but I think the computer
evaluation is quite okay it gives white
0.5 advantage does make sense it's not a
full porn but
it is something and the way it it was
played it was son immediately very
critical alright thanks for watching